we're very excited to share with you our
vision 401 incursions we'll introduce
the first of an all-new challenging
endgame activity developed specifically
for squad play this incursion will pit
you and your squad against a seemingly
unstoppable force and reward you with
some powerful new weapons and equipment
the second update will change the way
you play in the dark zone it will also
add a new incursion in the iconic
Columbus Circle in the first expansion
underground descend into the underbelly
of New York to save what remains deadly
enemies are regrouping in the endless
maze of tunnels and subways of the
underground how deep will your team go
in the second expansion survival will
you find enough essential supplies
throughout New York to survive and
secure high-tech equipment or will you
succumb like so many others to the
temptation to turn rogue a new threat is
rising in the third expansion Last Stand
you and your squad must prepare to
defend against a relentless foe recruit
other agents and build your defenses to
help you hold the line unlock all three
expansions along with extra VIP benefits
with the season pass Tom Clancy's the
division is an experience that will keep
evolving
where your agent will grow stronger as
you become more skilled additionally we
will be bringing new features over the
course they are starting with new
trading gear sets a much more free
contact it's gonna be a busy and
exciting year we hope you enjoy playing
everything we've got in store
Tom Clancy's the division available
March 8 pre-order now